et
du
m
oui
on savait où nous sommes
alors nous sommes sur le n s de la forêt
des hauts de montvert donc au situé sur
la commune de saint pierre
environ 1600 mètres d'altitude
alors la particularité donc de la forêt
des homes ont versé que donc déjà située
dans le coeur du parc national de la
réunion et
et puis c'est un site qui symbolise à
lui tout seul donc le patrimoine ce qui
donc
dans dans l'unesco en fait donc il ya
proximité donc du site un rempart
vertigineux 2000 mètres et puis une
forêt de bois de couloir qui y perd bien
préservés donc c'est un site qui
symbolise ce bien inscrit au patrimoine
mondial à lui tout seul
donc la forêt de montvert c'est une
forêt de poteaux cours d eau une forêt
de brouillard ou une forêt dans la brume
en fait fort et de mao avec beaucoup
donc de deux espèces endémiques comme le
franc jean le maho le mas poux loeffler
jeunes et c est la particularité de
cette forêt donc
c'est qu'elle situe donc en grande
partie dans le coeur du parc national de
la réunion
donc c'est la valeur elle est consacrée
en tout cas par ce parc national la
nouvelle recco logique est indéniable 1
et qui a été reconnue depuis les années
soixante dix en tout cas donc sur cet
art
alors les animaux qu'on va retrouver
d'ancrer dans la forêt des volontaires
sont principalement des oiseaux ou des
oiseaux endémiques
je vais citer donc le maire pays le saut
vers le technique avec une jolie robe
rousse sur la poitrine des mâles
notamment le chaque fois tous les as vu
la vierge le zozo blanc ont trouvé le
principal aux espèces
alors dans la forêt bois de couleur des
eaux du manager wallon va retrouver donc
des marots défend jean des fleurs jaunes
pour citer les principales le mois de
leur martin aussi avec une belle
floraison quand son de cloche
on retrouve aussi bois de piment donc
dans le fond de mon père la
particularité du bois de pin moins c'est
que les fruits ressemble beaucoup au
piment
sauf que c'est pas comme ici
m